[Music]
Jerry Ferrara the actor and he's got a
new show it's on Starz it's called power
Jerry plays an attorney who helps a
former drug lord turn businessman kind
of a kind of a new show this is season
three or four I believe is that right
let's bring in Jack
yeah Jerry hi Jerry he's in for Dan and
you know what I I couldn't help I was
listening and you brought me back to a
time when I thought I was lost six Emmys
in a row oh yeah you brought me right
back down on the sports I mean yeah I
remember those things I think often what
the Desperate Housewives showrunners
doing with there are three Emmys that
they beat us out on so I feel you how
was it though did you go to the Emmys oh
yeah we went we went six years in a row
and walked out you know at one point I
remember just like I swear saying if we
win one I will never you never have to
invite me back I just want one and uh
never got it never got it escaped us but
did entourage ever win an Emmy no we
went over six of the anyway Oh for seven
with the Golden Globe damn Jeremy Piven
won three Emmys in a row okay
and uh condoling Dillon had some
nominees my only other fact was if
Adrian got nominated before me that I
would had a really good cause I wasn't
the only one without without one so
anyway you brought me back in time how
you doing I'm doing well doing well I
was wondering about this when somebody
asked me who was on tirage really all
about like have you singled out one
character because I think that if you
you look at Vince it would seem like it
was Vince but I don't think it was about
Vince I'm gonna surprise you with who I
think entourage was all about I think it
was about Eric I think it went on Lee I
think here's the way I would put it
obviously you need the Vince character
to make the whole show work but the
whole entire series in my opinion was
always done through the point of view of
the Eric character he was like the moral
compass of the show and I would I would
cosign on
very good observation did anybody on who
else auditioned for Kevin Connolly's
role as he um you know honestly I truly
don't remember I think Kevin Connolly
was the guy for a moment one if memory
does serve me correctly though I think
at the time Connolly was so focused on
directing that he wasn't really even
open to think he was getting ready to
direct something so he wasn't even open
to auditioning or meeting for the pilot
it literally took like Wahlberg to tell
Kevin like listen go meet with Doug at
least you're gonna like throw away this
opportunity and talk them out of an
early retirement and thankfully we had
him for 10 years did who else
audition for pivens Ari Gold so role
know I believe was already when I
remember testing for the show I think
Timmy was already a part of the of the
cast now this is 2003 so I'm a little my
memory's a little hazy at this point but
I think Tim was already a part of the
cast
I do remember at one point Kevin Dillon
in the network cast and uh you know
network test they basically bring two or
three guys for four for each part and
Dylan stood up he said who else is here
reading for Johnny Drama and I think it
might even be Connolly saying we didn't
know each other at this point he said
nobody you probably got the plot music
oh I'm gonna go outside and grab a
smoker so yeah I think that I do
remember from the test
what was the storyline that your
surprise made it or so the script that
didn't make it I was I guess I don't
think I was surprised that it made it
but the whole I was always wondering how
we're gonna work in a guy go back to the
whole Wahlberg Tom Brady golfing I
wasn't like surprised that it made it
but I just remember thinking is this
gonna be something that people think is
really cool and and the stuff that my
character is saying like Tom Brady which
I won't repeat on your airwaves but I I
just were being really nervous about
that episode and just wondering is this
the end or is this the beginning in a
lot of ways and luckily I still that's
something that people on the street
especially giant fans still will yell at
me in in
cheering they'll say Tom Brady you know
what so but that one I just remember
being real nervous about yeah and I did
Brady Brady had a sense of humor about
it he was fantastic it was on the golf
course as you probably remember and you
know five o'clock in the morning we're
like getting ready to shoot I meet him
for the first time nice guy and we're
like messing around a hole he just picks
up a driver I think the guy swung a club
because this wasn't long after this was
the after the season he was injured so
he was just getting ready for its
comeback and I just picked up a club
we're on a par four it takes a nice 5
a.m. first thing in a day and like pipes
it like 300 yards down the middle and
I'm like shot if this guy could ask him
and he was he was pretty damn good
acting too so yeah
Jerry Ferrara the actor of the Starz
series is power and you're engaged
I am I'm engaging I'm engaged I'm
getting married in like four months
unbelievable
what's the game plan err okay who's in
has it been revealed who's invited ah
that stuff that's happening as we speak
I think that's like going down all next
week
invitations and stuff like that I don't
really get much of a say in all the
decisions so uh I think it's all going
down next week right look if you you got
my address so don't let's not even
embarrass any other people here with
this well I was gonna there maybe just
start lobbying a seat you be the
officiant you know you got that great
voice and I just thought that maybe you
as the officiant would be really really
cool how do you take this is what I do I
will introduce you and your wife at the
reception sort of like Jordan got
introduced with the Bulls and now mr.
and mrs. ladies and gentlemen yes he
never won an Emmy he never won a Tony
but boy did he win our hearts here look
at
mr. and mrs. Jerry Ferrara
okay just our hottie from Entourage get
invited yes of course does my favorite
girl get invited Emmanuel shrieking I
actually I ran into your favorite girl
yesterday did she ask Howard
did she ask about me you know how that's
a deal I but know there was something on
her mind he wanted to ask me I don't
know I think she was nervous but uh yes
I ran into her yesterday and she will be
attending dance so a little more
motivation for you it's a plus-one
boyfriend plus one why you got a room to
bed yeah my good friend I know her for
15 years yeah how's your bracket by the
way in the bracket challenger oh my lord
so I promise this is not a name job
because he's in he's in the the
celebrity challenge here but I was
working out at Glaser's gym in LA
unbreakable and Ryan Leaf approaches me
and man you're really at the bottom I
think that happened I'm like and it's
interest because Chrissy started
reaching out to me on Monday and they
want to talk to me so I think I got to
take my medicine here yeah I had a
horrible bracket
I am I tied for last with Josh to model
is that correct yeah yeah pretty boy
Josh Duhamel I got a well yeah I know
and that's the thing if he loses he's
still pretty could you out bench Josh
Duhamel kind of I mean it depends on
what kind of shape he's in you know I I
still hold that beach bowl victory over
his head very very that's like every
time I see him I bring up that P do you
did you get a trophy for the DirecTV
beach bowl you were the NBA you
presented yeah can you can you take a
picture of that and tweet it out that
would be my happy
so you didn't win an Emmy you didn't win
a Tony but you won a Direct TV MVP award
a DirecTV MVP woo and I swear if I do
ever win an Emmy this I have part of my
success I'm waiting today and it's gonna
involve thanking my mom and the only
other trophy I won was the sportsmanship
award and Lily and my mom got me that
award there was times where she was
upset I didn't get in in the seventh
inning and I say mom don't blow this for
us
I'm leading the votes for the
sportsmanship award iiiiii i wanted to
ask you about working with clint
eastwood's didn't you work with him on
Sully oh okay now we talked to you right
after you got the job but I didn't talk
to you about the actual experience of
Clint Eastwood because he's famous for
not doing a lot of takes and you know
just kind of get to the point get your
job done and then move on how did it go
we definitely did more than one take I
will say that so that kind of myth was
dispelled for me right there but um the
one thing I wasn't that I had heard they
didn't know if it was true and wasn't
ready is there's definitely not a like a
big deal when you're getting ready to
call action like she's kind of off on
his own with a monitor and you know the
actors are kind of standing around and
usually you're waiting for you - no more
steps than me you know rolling and
action and it kind of just doesn't hey
he kind of comes in just goes whenever
you're ready and walk it out and start
whenever you want and and you never
quite and you don't really ever hear cut
you just you just gotta mmm it really it
really was be like being prepared for
anything and it was an awesome story I
was ready for like if you did one take
and moved on I I just would have been so
has this would have been amazing it was
more than one thing I figure three how
was Hanks only bump into him for one day
at just the best awesome like kid he's
unbelievable he should absolutely
continue to be Tom Hanks just everything
you want he's phenomenal did you enter
I did it quick like hey I'm really bad
I'm really really I'm really awkward in
those situations
hey more importantly good luck with the
wedding there
sounds like you finally found your your
girl so good luck with that
damn good to hear from you and yeah look
for a sweat out I'm gonna go cold my
hair and tweet out a photo of me with
this MVP trophy more but more
importantly please tell Manuel shrieky
I'm there if she needs a dance partner
Oh we'd like to invite all the couples
is there gonna be open bar because if
there's not open bar I probably won't go
even if the Manuel straight he invites
me yeah the only thing that I was
passionate about was the food in the
park yes there is there is open bar
there I love that great talk to you
buddy Thank You Jer
all right that's Jerry Ferrara the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience